bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va à
nouveau parler de l'expansion accélérée
de l'univers dans la dernière vidéo je
vous avais présenté les observations
astrophysiques surprenantes qui ont
montré il y a 25 ans que nous vivions
vraisemblablement dans un univers en
expansion accéléré mais dans cette
première vidéo je n'avais pas détaillé
les théories qui pourraient expliquer ce
résultat étonnant alors aujourd'hui on
va passer en revue les différentes
explications possibles pour cette
expansion accélérée et comment on peut
la prendre en compte dans les modèles
cosmologiques et pour ça on va notamment
évoquer la fameuse énergie sombre cette
substance mystérieuse qui expliquerait
peut-être l'accélération de l'expansion
on va essayer de comprendre ce qu'elle
signifie et surtout si on en a vraiment
besoin pour comprendre l'expension
accélérée de l'univers il faut se
pencher sur les modèles cosmologiques
qui avaient été élaborés initialement
pour expliquer l'expansion de l'Univers
au tout court avant qu'on ne se rende
compte de son accélération ces modèles
sont fondamentalement basée sur la
théorie de la relativité générale vous
savez sans doute que cette théorie nous
dit en gros que la gravité serait due à
la courbure de l'espace-temps et que
cette courbure serait créée par la
présence de matière et d'énergie alors
plus précisément il existe une équation
qui relie d'un côté la courbure de
l'espace-temp et de l'autre son contenu
en matière il s'agit de l'équation
d'Einstein que vous voyez ici écrite
avec des notations un peu ésotériques le
terme de gauche représente la courbure
ou plutôt c'est une fonction de la
courbure et le terme de droite
représente la matière au sens large et
dépend non seulement de sa masse mais
aussi de son énergie de sa pression de
son impulsion et cetera l'équation a
l'air très compacte ici mais en fait ce
sont des notations qui cachent une
dizaine d'équations beaucoup plus
compliquées et qui relient ces
différents aspects de la courbure de
l'espace-temps et de la matière dans le
cas général ces équations sont
impossibles à résoudre et pour faire de
la cosmologie on va devoir faire des
simplifications l'hypothèse habituelle
en cosmologie cela consiste à supposer
que l'univers est à la fois homogène et
isotrope c'est-à-dire qu'il est
approximativement similaire en tous ces
points et identique dans toutes les
directions c'est une hypothèse forte
mais pas absurde hein quand on regarde
l'univers à grande échelle on constate
qu'il semble plutôt en effet homogène et
isotrope avec cette simplification les
équations d'Einstein se réduisent à deux
équations beaucoup plus faciles à
traiter les équations de Friedman et la
principale inconnue dans ces équations
c'est ce qu'on appelle le facteur
d'échelle noté petite a de T et qui
représente l'échelle des distances dans
l'univers à un instant T rapporté aux
distances actuelles par convention le
facteur d'échelle vaut 1 aujourd'hui et
son évolution permet de suivre les
éventuels mouvements d'expansion ou de
contraction de l'univers et c'est cette
évolution qui qui est justement gouverné
par les équations de Friedman alors je
vais pas rentrer dans les détails des
équations mais du côté de la matière
vous voyez peut-être qu'on a deux
quantités intéressante la densité
d'énergie notée R et la pression notée P
et ces deux quantités vont aussi évoluer
au cours du temps si jamais l'univers
s'étend ou se contracte et là même sans
comprendre le détail des équations vous
voyez peut-être qu'on a un petit
problème on a trois inconnus a R et P et
seulement deux équations donc ça va être
compliqué à résoudre
pour que ça marche il en faudrait une
troisème intuitivement on se dit que la
densité R et la pression P devrai être
relié prenez un gaz il y a un lien entre
ces deux quantités c'est d'ailleurs ce
quiexprime par exemple la loi des gaz
parfaits le lien entre densité et
pression en général on appelle ça une
équation
d'état pour pouvoir résoudre les
équations de Freedman il faut qu'on
ajoute une équation d'état pour relier
densité et pression et celle-ci va
dépendre du type type de matière que
l'on veut voir figurer dans notre
univers il faut donc qu'on fasse une
hypothèse sur la nature de la matière
présente l'hypothèse la plus simple et
la plus radicale c'est de supposer que
la pression est nulle ou du moins
négligeable ça revient à supposer que la
matière principale qui peupple l'univers
est en gros un gaz froid plutôt dilué
dont les molécules ont des vitesses
d'agitation très inférieur à la vitesse
de la lumière techniquement cette
hypothèse c'est ce que les cosmologistes
appellent un fluide de poussière alors
c'est pas de la poussière au sens commun
du mot hein c'est juste le terme dédié
pour parler de cette matière à pression
négligeable et c'est pas absurde comme
supposition hein c'est même assez
raccord avec ce qu'on sait du contenu
actuel de l'univers alors essayons de
poser que la pression est nulle et
résolvons les équations alors je vous ai
parlé des calculs détaillés hein mais ce
qui nous permett de trouver c'est
l'évolution du facteur d'échelle au
cours du temps à la fois dans le passé
et vers l'avenir il y a plusieurs
scénarios qui vont dépendre de la
densité de matière présente actuellement
dans l'univers
je vous avais déjà présenté ces
résultats de simulation dans la vidéo
précédente on voit que pour les
scénarios avec une densité de matière
élevée l'univers finit par se
recontracter et on a une fin de type Big
Crunch et en dessous d'une certaine
densité critique on a plutôt une
expansion éternelle mais notez que
malgré tout cette expansion est toujours
de plus en plus lente dans tous les
scénarios c'est une expansion
décéléré ça c'est donc pour le fluide de
poussière mais on aurait aussi pu
prendre une autre hypothèse
imaginez un gaz très chaud dont les
molécules ont des vitesses d'agitation
proche de celle de la lumière voire
carrément un univers rempli de
rayonnement de photons avec ces
suppositions on ne peut plus prendre une
pression nulle des formes de matière de
ce genre ont une équation d'état dans
laquelle la pression est égale à 1/3 de
la densité d'énergie et si on injecte ça
dans la résolution des équations ben ça
produit des scénarioos légèrement
différents des précédents voyez ici les
courbes ce sont des trajectoires
possibles pour l'univers dans le passé
et dans le futur en supposant qu'il ne
soit rempli que de rayonnement de
photons on retrouve bien les scénarios
de Big Crunch et d'expansion éternelle
mais les courbes sont un peu différentes
du cas de la poussière qui avait une
pression nulle en revanche on a toujours
uniquement de la décélération
l'expansion n'est jamais accélérée dans
aucun de ces scénarios pour espérer
expliquer l'expansion accélérée de
l'univers il va falloir essayer autre
chose et l'idée la plus immédiate c'est
ce qu'on appelle la constante
cosmologique il s'agit d'une
modification des équations d'Einstein
qui avait déjà été envisagée par
Einstein
lui-même lors de ces premières
recherches sur les conséquences de la
relativité général Einstein avait en
effet déjà compris que son équation
impliquait un univers qui pouvait être
globalement dynamique qui pouvait
notamment se contracter sous l'effet de
sa propre matière comme il n'imait pas
trop cette idée Einstein avait alors
essayer de s'en débarrasser en modifiant
son équation de façon à introduire une
sorte de force répulsive qui
compenserait exactement l'effet de
l'effondrement mais quelques années plus
tard quand l'éloignement des galaxies
avait été mis en évidence par Hubble et
expliqué par le maître Einstein avait
rangé son idée au placard mais la
découverte de l'expansion accélérée 70
ans après lui a donné un nouvel intérêt
alors voyons comment pour créer une
sorte d'effet répulsif Einstein avait
décidé d'ajouter un terme à sa fameuse
équation ce terme fait intervenir une
nouvelle constante fondamentale qu'on
note généralement lambda et qu'on
appelle la constante cosmologique un
point important à souligner dans cette
modification c'est que ça n'est pas
juste une bidouille adéquate faite pour
que ça marche il y a un truc assez
profond avec ce nouveau terme de
l'équation car c'est en fait le seul
possible il faut savoir que lors de
l'élaboration de sa théorie d'origine
Einstein avait pas mal tâtonné pour
déterminer exactement ce qu'il fallait
mettre du du côté gauche de son équation
il avait essayé plusieurs choses mais
avait fini par remarquer que pour des
raisons de symétrie il n'y avait que
deux termes possibles celui qui figure
initialement dans l'équation d'Einstein
est ce nouveau terme avec la constante
cosmologique et donc si on veut
considérer la théorie la plus générale
possible qui respecte les principes de
symétrie il faut a priori s'autoriser
ces deux term de toute façon il y en a
aucun autre qui pourrait coller si on
admet cette modification cela provoque
un ajustement des équations de Friedman
qui conduit à de nouvelles formes pour
les courbes d'évolution du facteur
d'échelle et cela produit notamment des
situations d'expansion
accélérée c'est ce que vous voyez dans
la courbe en rouge ici comparé aux
anciennes en bleu on a une expansion
accélérée et en plus cette courbe colle
très bien aux mesures astrophysiques de
distance et de décalage dont on a parlé
dans la vidéo précédente ces mesures qui
avaient justement permis de détecter
l'accélération de l'expansion l'univers
donc finalement on conserve notre
matière et on rajoute juste un nouveau
terme dans l'équation avec cette
constante cosmologique lambda et en
déterminant sa valeur à partir des
observations on a un truc simple et qui
colle nickel en fait c'est quoi sa
valeur justement cette constante et bien
c'est pas très parlant car l'unité est
un peu étrange mais ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que la constante cosmologique
contribuerait à elle seul à 70 % de
l'évolution actuelle dans l'univers qui
va dans le sens d'une accélération
contre seulement 30 % pour la matière
qui elle œuvre pour la décélération et
cette valeur de 70 % est corroborée par
d'autres mesures astrophysiquees
indépendantes comme l'analyse des
fluctuations du rayonnement fossile dont
j'ai déjà parlé dans d'autres vidéos
donc ça colle vraiment super bien et là
j'ai envie de dire bah on pourrait
s'arrêter là on a une explication qui
colle parfaitement avec les observations
qui implique juste une modification de
l'équation d'Einstein qui était som tout
assez naturelle on a déterminé la valeur
de la constante cosmologique et c'est
juste bah une constante fondamentale
supplémentaire à côté de la constante de
Newton par exemple alors oui ça marche
bien mais si on veut éviter de devoir
bidouiller l'équation d'instein et
d'invoquer une nouvelle constante c'est
quand même pas rien on peut peut-être
essayer de trouver une autre option et
notamment en se demandant si
l'accélération ne serait pas d plutôt à
une nouvelle forme de matière présente
dans
l'univers
revenons un peu sur les équations de
Friedman mais sans la constante
cosmologique la deuxième équation est ce
qu'on appelle l'équation d'accélération
la raison c'est qu'elle fait intervenir
la dérivée seconde du facteur d'échelle
c'est pour ça qu'il y a deux points
auudessus et regardez le signe de ce
qu'il y a à droite on a un signe moins
et à l'intérieur des parenthèses la
densité et la pression vous voyez bien
que quoi qu'on fasse l'accélération va
être négative l'univers sera forcément
en décélération on n'a pas le choix sauf
sauf si ce qu'il y a dans la parenthèse
est négatif est-ce qu'on peut pas
trouver une forme de matière pour
laquelle ce soit le cas on l'a vu pour
choisir une forme de matière il faut
choisir son équation d'état généralement
on prend des formes de matière dont la
pression est proportionnelle à la
densité d'énergie c'est la forme la plus
simple si on appelle le double V le
facteur de proportionnalité entre les
deux l'équation d'état générique c'est
donc p é= W X rou ici W n'a pas d'unité
hein c'est un nombre sans dimension et
on peut faire varier W pour modéliser
différentes formes de matière alors
souvenez-vous tout à l'heure le fluide
de poussière c'était W = 0 puisque la
pression était nulle et les photons ou
le fluide de matière relativiste c'était
W = 1/3 mais on peut mettre l'équation
d'état générique avec W dans l'équation
de l'accélération et voici ce qu'on
obtient ce qu'on aimerait donc c'est
rendre le contenu de la parenthèse
négatif et pour ça bah pas le choix en
fait il faut un W négatif si on le prend
inférieur à - 1/3 et ben ça marche
l'accélération devient positive et on
obtient un univers en expansion
accélérée prendre un W négatif ça
signifie envisager de la matière avec
une pression négative ça paraît un peu
bizarre mais en tout cas ça marcherait
et on peut d'ailleurs le voir dans les
modèles je vous ai tracé ici différents
évolutions possibles du facteur
d'échelle pour la même densité de
matière mais en faisant cette fois
varier le W ça correspond pas forcément
à des scénarios crédibles mais c'est
pour montrer l'effet souvenez-vous en
bleu W = 0 c'était la matière froide en
vert W = 1/ les photons ou la matière
relativiste et on voit l'impact des
valeurs négatives du W qui provoque une
expansion accélérée notamment pour W
inférieur à
1/3 donc une forme de matière avec un W
négatif inférieur à Mo- un/3 ça pourrait
arranger nos affaires mais qu'est-ce que
ça veut dire physiquement est-ce que ça
a une chance d'exister et ben oui
pourquoi pas une première chose
importante à comprendre là-dedans c'est
que je ne suis pas en train de parler de
masse négative ou d'antiravité non non
la densité d'énergie est bien positive
c'est juste la pression associée qui est
négative qu'est-ce que ça veut dire une
pression négative pour le comprendre il
faut se demander ce qu'il advient de la
D ité d'énergie quand l'univers se
dilate commençons avec un cas simple le
fluide de poussière ou W = 0 imaginons
un fluide avec une certaine densité
allez disons 8 molécules par mètre cube
si l'univers s'étend d'un facteur 2 les
volumes augmenteront d'un facteur 2 au
cube donc 8 ça fait qu'il n'y aura plus
qu'une molécule par mètre Cu en moyenne
la densité d'énergie de la matière
ordinaire diminue avec l'expansion et
elle diminue comme le facteur d'échelle
au cube c'est logique hein c'est une
simple dilution al maintenant faisons le
même raisonnement avec des photons
imaginez qu'on a disons photons par
mètre cube et qu'ils aient une énergie
correspondant à une longueur d'onde de
400 nanomè et supposons à nouveau que
l'univers se dilate d'un facteur 2 d'un
côté les photons seront dilués d'un
facteur 8 he comme pour la poussière et
il n en aura plus qu'un par mère Cu mais
en plus leur longueur d'onde aussi sera
affectée par l'expansion de l'Univers
elle passera de 400 à 800 nanomè donc
l'énergie de chaque photon sera aussi
diminuée de moitié avec les photons hein
longueur d'onde plus élevé énergie plus
faible au total la densité d'énergie des
photons aura donc été divisée par 16
elle aura été plus que simplement dilué
elle aura diminué comme le facteur
d'échelle à la puissance
4 de façon générale on peut montrer
qu'un fluide ayant une équation d'état
avec W va se diluer comme le facteur
d'échelle à la puissance 3 x 1 + W alors
ça a l'air compliqué comme ça mais
brancher les valeurs et on retrouve ce
qu'on a dit hein la poussière W = 0 ça
fait le cube et les photons W é= 1/3 ça
fait puissance 4 maintenant si vous
prenez W é= par exemple - 1/3 vous
trouvez que ça diminuerait comme le
carré ça veut dire que la densité
d'énergie ferait moins que se diluer il
se passerait comme l'inverse d'avec les
photons comme si les particules se
diluer en volume mais l'énergie de
chaque particule augmenterait avec
l'expansion de l'Univers et alors dans
le cas extrême W = -1 on voit que la
densité d'énergie ne se diluerait plus
du tout elle resterait constante au
cours de la dilatation donc l'énergie
totale augmenterait proportionnellement
au volume alors là certains me diront
peut-être attends on crée de l'énergie
là comme ça partir de rien l'énergie
c'est pas conservée alors c'est
compliqué mais retenez qu'en relativité
générale ben non la conservation usuel
de l'énergie est remplacé par quelque
chose de plus générique et donc on ne
peut pas simplement compter l'énergie
comme on le ferait en physique classique
d'ailleurs on l'a vu avec les photons
l'expansion fait augmenter leur longueur
d'onde donc baisser leur énergie alors
pourquoi pas imaginer l'inverse une
forme de matière dont l'énergie augmente
quand on la dilate et c'est d'ailleurs
exactement ce que signifie une pression
négative prenez un gaz normal pas en
cosmologie he juste dans les conditions
terrestres enfermons ce gaz dans un
cylindre avec un piston le gaz a une
certaine pression P positive si j'exerce
une force sur le piston pour le déplacer
un peu pour l'enfoncer je fais du
travail et ce travail augmente l'énergie
de mon gaz et dans le même temps j'ai
diminué son volume inversement si je
laisse le piston remonter le volume
augmente et l'énergie du gaz diminue
donc ce lien entre variation d'énergie
et de volume le coefficient de
proportionalité c'est la pression du gaz
pour ceux qui font de la thermo c'est
même la définition de la pression en
fait pour une substance à W négatif on a
vu c'est l'effet inverse si j'augmente
son volume
l'énergie totale contenue dans le
système augmente au lieu de diminuer et
c'est la définition d'une pression
négative ça n'est pas si incongru que ça
un cas séduisant on l'a vu c'est de
regarder une forme de matière avec W =
-1 dont la densité d'énergie ne se
diluerait pas du tout et serait
constante comme si le vide lui-même
avait une énergie proportionnelle à son
volume et c'est cette hypothétique
substance qu'on appelle parfois
l'énergie sombre et si on met cette
énergie sombre dans les équations de
Friedman on constate une chose étonnante
ça produit dans les équations exactement
la même chose qu'une constante
cosmologique formellement c'est
complètement identique ça veut dire
qu'une manière de se représenter l'effet
physique de la constante cosmologique
c'est de la voir comme équivalente à une
forme d'énergie sombre une énergie du
vide avec une pression négative dont la
densité d'énergie fixerait la valeur de
la constante alors petit détail amusant
au lieu d'une énergie sombre classique
on peut aussi pousser plus loin et
prendre des valeurs de W inférieur à -1
alors là carrément l'expansion provoque
une augmentation de la densité d'énergie
c'est ce que les cosmologistes appellent
l'énergie fantôme et dans les équations
ça conduit à une conséquence amusante au
lieu d'une expansion accélérée mais
infinie ça fait une expansion tellement
violente qu'elle déchire l'espace-temp
et l'univers en un temps fini c'est
sympa aussi comme destin
[Musique]
bien faisons donc un petit bilan des
solutions qui s'offrent à nous pour
tenter de comprendre l'origine de
l'expansion accélérée de l'univers d'un
côté on peut juste modifier l'équation
d'Einstein ajouter une constante
cosmologique dont on détermine la valeur
par l'expérience et puis c'est tout de
l'autre on peut ajouter une nouvelle
forme de matière avec une équation
d'état à pression négative il existe
plein de solutions suivant comment on
choisit le fameux W et en particulier
choisir W = -1 donne formellement
exactement le même résultat que la
constante cosmologique une énergie
sombre qui se comporte comme une énergie
associée au vide aujourd'hui en
combinant les données de plusieurs
mesures astrophysiques indépendantes sur
les supernovas sur le rayonnement
fossile on trouve qu'expérimentalement
la valeur de W la plus crédible c'est
-1,03 plus ou moins
0,03 autant dire que les observations
sont très consistantes avec simplement W
é= mo-1 mais vous voyez qu'une fois
qu'on a dit ça on reste quand même avec
une sorte d'ambiguïé on peut obtenir ces
équations par deux choix assez
différents une simple constante
cosmologique qui modifie l'équation
d'instein dans sa partie gauche ou une
nouvelle substance qui s'ajoute dans la
partie droite mais l'effet sera le même
en revanche les conséquences sur le
travail des chercheurs sont un peu
différentes si on dit que c'est une
substance une énergie sombre qui compose
70 % de l'univers alors on a très envie
de trouver d'où elle vient notamment on
peut peut-être détecter de légères
variations de sa densité dans l'espace
ou au cours du temps et préciser ses
caractéristiques comme d'ailleurs on
cherche à le faire avec la matière noire
mais à contrario certains physiciens
sont assez critiques de cette façon de
présenter les choses et considère qu'on
a juste une simple constante
cosmologique et qu'il n'y a rien à
détecter de plus expérimentalement par
contre on aura plutôt envie d'essayer
d'expliquer cette constante avec une
théorie plus fondamentale par exemple
une théorie de l'énergie du vide
quantique
une des expériences qui permettra
bientôt d'en savoir plus c'est la
mission Euclide un télescope spatial qui
a été lancé en juillet 2023 il aura pour
objectif de mesurer certains phénomènes
de déformation de l'image des galaxies
pour mieux reconstituer l'histoire de
l'évolution du facteur d'échelle et donc
en savoir peut-être un peu plus sur
cette fameuse énergie sonde voilà c'est
tout pour aujourd'hui merci d'avoir
suivi la vidéo si vous voulez pas rater
les prochaines vidéos abonnez-vous
mettez la cloche vous pouvez aussi
rejoindre le serveur discord de
le lien est en description et puis moi
je vous dis à très vite pour de
nouvelles vidéos à
[Musique]
bientôt